ahead only a tough day at the office
the question was hotel i'm going to do
what i've done every day for the last
year
lead the country through a pandemic so
we'll see you all later
on her desk as she arrived at work was
the report into whether nicola sturgeon
had broken the ministerial code
potentially a resignation effect
on the ministerial floor of saint
andrews house the sun shone on a first
minister
who seemed to smile as she took her seat
for a meeting with advisers
she had cause to because james hamilton
dismissed allegations
that she broke the ministerial code in
not recording meetings and phone calls
with her predecessor alex salmond
following complaints against him
mr hamilton said she didn't mislead
parliament about those meetings
nor did she attempt to intervene in the
investigation of complaints
or fail to comply with the law in how
she dealt with mr salmon's legal
challenge
of her government's investigation
section 18 of that report is
unequivocal he says in terms that having
looked at all of the i think there's
four
key allegations were made against me in
relation to the ministerial code and
he's considered all of the
evidence he's considered all of the
material that was put to him and
unequivocally not on the one hand on the
other hand but unequivocally he says
i did not reach the ministerial code and
you know i think that is important and
i said i would accept the outcome of mr
hamilton's
inquiry and i think it is now incumbent
on others
to accept the outcome of it as well this
affair arose from the scottish
government's botched and unlawful
investigation
into harassment complaints against
nicolas sturgeon's predecessor alex
salmond
this is important for nicola sturgeon
but the saga
doesn't end here it will be followed
shortly by the publication in full
of a report by the scottish parliament's
harassment committee
it has concluded that she misled
parliaments
the scottish parliament will hold a
tuesday vote of no confidence in the
first minister
which she will survive with the support
of the green msps
if not the others there are still some
serious issues that
no one has taken responsibility for yet
the fact that two women have been failed
do we have a robust a harassment policy
that gives confidence to people coming
forward
in future about the transparency and the
role of parliament that's also really
important
about our judiciary and the role of the
lord advocate also a huge issue there
and also issues around the use of public
money these are all big questions that
still remain unanswered
the political recriminations are
guaranteed for nicola sturgeon
more importantly for her for now is the
political
survival james matthews sky news
edinburgh